all right and we are
live the last word with lord cognito in
ivanti special
saturday campfire edition returning how
you doing sir
uh doing good been busy uh just trying
to make this thing with a little work
thing i had uh but we have an awesome
guest tonight fair warning for everybody
this could be a mature show
this evening it's a saturday night
campfire special so you know the gloves
are off tonight so
we gonna chat it up this evening but sir
let's welcome our
fantastical guest here it's yours let's
bring him in right
welcome to the last word episode number
139
and it's another glorious saturday here
in the states and we're back in front of
the destiny carefire for some more lunar
shooter discussion
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest so we're going to get right into
it
i want to introduce a lord who is not
only one of the absolute pillars within
our destiny law community with his
weekly lore videos
but also had the amazing distinction of
being immortalized by bungie
in regards to our sacred grimoire
introducing the creating host of the
mylon games youtube and twitch channels
co-host of the destiny down under
podcast and lore curator of the destiny
grimoire
anthology vol 1
our favorite complaining hunter boy
who is by far the most hilarious
streamer of halo for the first time
live from australia and kind enough to
make his debut
at the campfire of the last verb
mommy lloyd milan games how you doing
sarah
i like how i think every australian
should get a just a language warning
or maybe you don't even need the
language warning you just go look guys
we've got an aussie on
okay it's a different set of rule sets
those won't be there you'll hear some
new ones tonight
no thanks thanks uh thanks for having me
i'm sorry my my alarm went off in the
middle of the intro to make sure i was
here
yeah and make sure i was
you satisfied all of those requests you
did well
well i like that i like that brother
price preaching she's taking the time
man i know we've been scheduled this for
a while
fresh off a wedding you know what i'm
saying
man congratulations appreciate you yeah
appreciate you making the time man but
you could you would get started on them
with some questioning
yeah no i mean for me it just kind of
goes back like for your gaming journey
just like the ones that you hit off for
us just there's some big ones but
um when it comes to shooters you go all
the back
all the way back to like n64 and
goldeneye
that's one i mean were you i gotta ask
like you
and your friends or would they be like
mates again i'll probably get the words
all wrong
like was that a big couch co-op one for
you as well as that kind of where it
started for
shooters or did anything else like hit
bigger than goldeneye for a shooter
uh gold now is definitely the first
shooter
it's sort of funny because because i've
got gravitated to
law i'm probably quite far away from pvp
but most of like my gaming preference is
always
actually pvp or at least couch co-op and
then and then moving from there so it's
sort of
it's sort of funny how it ended up in
law because people like ah i don't care
about
versing each other just tell me a story
yeah um and it's funny because my i have
a twin brother and you know we had to
obviously share the console and he
he would um be in legend of zelda and
i'll be like let's play double 07. and
it was just
so opposite and we had to share the
nintendo and i'm like
dude zelda's i mean let's see once again
all my audience probably
loves zelda
story and law but i'm like man i just
want to play some double 07. i want to
get some cheat codes
speed run submissions i want to be odd
job come on just one
time yeah so a lot of a lot of four
players split screen with with that with
some mates
um i don't know if you've played double
seven recently but
probably don't just let nostalgia let it
stay
yes memories is something that was
actually good
some things don't age well and like the
n64 like early 3d graphics like you can
you can take mario 64 for kind of what
it is but yeah some of that stuff
doesn't age all too well
yeah yeah shooters with shooters with a
single stick
uh is uh interesting experience
i totally forgot about the controller i
forgot about those just before the dual
analog
error and the yeah yeah you're just
literally
said perfect dark too that was that that
was changing as well
i went straight into perfect dark after
gold knife the many use of that
nice bit of mario kart are you excited
about the i guess
new one apparently yeah i haven't
i remember seeing a little bit i mean
like but i don't think they really
showed much
no i remember seeing a bit about it and
i was like oh that's cool like i'll be
i'll be checking that out but i can't
remember much more
it's like the quadruple a or whatever
microsoft wants to call that
it's like their big studios behind
perfect dark i was very intrigued that
that was that title it's very cool yeah
yeah absolutely
yeah man i mean tremendous gaming
history another thing that i got to ask
you about
is that uh obviously you've been
recently getting back
into getting into halo with fresh eyes
from what i understand
so how did that start was it like
someone pressured you like yo you are
dead destiny guy you need to play this
like how did this whole thing because i
watched you in a warthog
try to cross over some sections of one
of those halo c
and i literally lost it you were
hilarious brother
the videos that he does is classic so
how did that start
um i actually think look i
i'm pretty highly critical of any
content i make and i guess
um more recently oh sudden
i guess this started when when covert
started last year actually
um just thinking about wanting
when i finished my phd wanted to
transition into
content creation full-time and what that
would involve and not being
so niche because you know destiny's not
going to live forever
um and if you know the law i am in a
pretty good section in destiny a lot of
people
might not play the game but would still
listen to the stories and
and law so for sure um but really just
trying to diversify
and i pretty sure it was just a trailer
i think it was a halo infinite trailer
we were just goofing around
beginning of a stream um i
i didn't have any plan for the stream
that day and i made a joke i said oh
i've never played halo before
and then that was sort of the entire
chat
what i was like and i was sort of i
i that's a bit of a lie i had played
halo the kid up the road had an xbox
but i've ne i never played the campaign
we only ever played
uh multiplayer yeah yeah and
so you know i only had memories of that
and it was only at a friend's place i
never had had one myself so i was like
oh why not everyone seems to be losing
their mind and i'll give it a crack and
uh
it gave me a new perspective on bungie
really and i sort of i didn't understand
that where the hype from destiny came
from
and the legacy of bungie uh
and i almost like yeah
halo is it probably more in a box of it
changed my life than destiny is
just because wow man i think it's
masterpiece i honestly do i think it's
one of the best games i've made
and now it's like and the fact that i
can play it two decades later and still
and feel that way about a game is
pretty special so you know i'm still
waiting for the next high of strength
like
the next game that gives me that same
feeling on the stream
and i don't know if it will because it
was this perfect storm of
my audience being you know halo fans
mean
somehow never playing halo and having
nothing already spoiled and and just
being this perfect mesh and it was and
it was also
locked down and people stuck at home so
it was just perfect like
sort of escape to nostalgia which was
just
really i mean it was really really fun
um so i've actually finished
the first highlight series which
i think is some of my best content it
doesn't perform very well because uh
no one's really searching for halo no
what's
that's like the whole youtube algorithm
but sometimes you got to make a video
you want to make and that's part of
content for sure so it's like if you
enjoyed it and you had that like you
know existential of an experience from
it
it's worth it whether in like five you
know whether
five other people see that end up
playing it through halo because they
missed it as well
that's sometimes like the good ones that
you get out there because some of the
comments you'll probably see on that one
might be a little more special than like
the average destiny one because it's so
different
so yeah yeah yeah you definitely get
like
um polarized comments some people that
because i think you know you guys
obviously see me on the on
the ddu and twitch but there's a huge
portion of my audience that's only ever
heard me
speak nicely um and calmly
and never they've only i've seen that
for seven years so it's a bit of a shock
to the system um when i'm a bit
uh more relaxed uh and i know
and i get that and uh that's a funny
thing though
i think i've tricked people into
thinking i'm just a law nerd right
that's what it is that's what makes it
so great like it's this
again there's so there's a big section
of people who
only know you as the smooth calm
lore master who gives us these great
stories and
these great imagery shout out to gamma
traps i love what you guys do together
too yeah and it's like um
it's so cool but then it's like you see
you unleash
especially pvp or crucible and then with
this halo series it's so funny
shout out your sound effects whatever
you make a mistake
is hilarious i love that little that
little squeegee noise that you do
classic classic i love all the little
things you throw in
like you have fun with it and it's a
personality that a lot of people
don't see from you they just think
you're just some you know always quiet
cool kind of guy and it's kind of fun
you know
well you've got like the radio podcast
voice just throw it on in the car and be
like i am
i'm chilling like good vibes switches
over to the next video and you're like
what is this
yeah yeah yeah that's true as well
sometimes uh
you know in a good way a lot of people
say they
they listen to my videos to relax or to
sleep
um so i can imagine that
next in playlist is probably not
conducive to getting a good night's rest
um
but that's where they started to make
that section
yeah they'll all of a sudden wake up and
they have a feeling to play halo
um that that's where it all started
really was
was trying to diversify um not only on
youtube but also on twitch
and uh honestly haley was a gateway for
me
because before that i was still pretty
reserved on twitch i think i was still
trying to fit into the law master box
um and it was pretty draining because it
was just it was just
a constant barrage of law questions it
was like
you know i wouldn't like someone just
come in
tell me about this serious like obscure
theory on orex or something
when i said chrysalis and oryx do you
think
and i was i was like oh did you know how
much
i spent hours researching one topic you
want me to answer this
like you know i'm just gonna pop off an
answer like i got my encyclopedia but i
want to reference it
it's a good point so so we do we still
do a little bit but
you know especially when new law comes
out we'll we'll we'll put the
the the hats on and the spinfall hats on
and we'll read through some of the new
uh
lord tabs but halo was i think a big
like you say uh
uh eye opener for a big portion of my
audience to sort of see another side
and also gave me a huge confidence boost
to stream other games and to
just be a little bit closer to myself
without
it's it's in the reign of voice on yeah
it's good to sometimes just be you
as opposed to having to kind of really
fit into another box as you said so it's
nice to
just to be a little more comfortable not
quite feel as on and just have a little
bit more freedom and fun
and the same thing like outriders
recently i've been hooked on that a
bunch lately and you said you've played
it a little bit too
and it's i've been i've got it's good 50
hours
which is a problem so i might even have
more than that i've got a whole bunch
seriously wow yeah i played it a bit uh
a bit it's mitch it it look
i i did a review on this too actually uh
on the channel which was
not quite screaming halo marlin and not
quite
uh law nerd milan so it was a little bit
in between um
i and i i i absolutely because after
halo we did this whole nostalgia trip
and we played every
game that i missed on xbox basically
titanfall 2 we did
time for two was it's freaking amazing
it is so good
it is so good yeah um
and then i had this stint of games i
just absolutely hated until i had to
stop
um sorry if people like gears of war but
i
absolutely i just i don't handle it
all right i heard you guys i've played i
played
i haven't played any i tried five looked
pretty
combat was kind of cool i did just
didn't stick with me and granted i don't
have the history in the franchise how
many did you play
or how many how many did you get through
i didn't even get the first one
oh did i i may have did gears of war one
i don't even know i do you know what i
cover shooters is not the thing um i
feel like
the writing was probably edgy and cool
when you're like a teenage boy back in
the day but
like it's it's pretty it's pretty rough
come back
and then just character design just
really didn't click with me
every time
what is his dude
head like heavyweight meathead
whatever it's called yeah something so i
look i went into outriders thinking this
is going to be true like i actually
in a bit of a mean way in a bit of a i
played anthem the day before
because i was like preparing prepare
yourself oh my god
so i streamed anthem ironically i bought
it the day before they closed production
and i accidentally bought it twice
that's a long story oh man
so i bought anthem twice the day before
before
i don't think anybody else can have
claim to that at all never yeah so
that's all yours
did that and i was like this is because
i was getting big anthem vibes from
outriders and i was like i don't see the
point
and i also don't like cover shooters and
i got in there and i'm like
i think this game has potential i i
think it's hitting a lot of notes
i still don't like the you know the
third person
but their abilities and the builds and
the rpg elements
so nice so far that if there's enough
end game content
it's it's something that i'll be jumping
into and playing a lot
yeah it's like for me the same way have
you touched it yet cognito i know you've
been busy
i've i've def i did once but uh
my experience i don't want to comment
yet because my experience
was it was your earliest yeah because i
had um
from what i was told pyromancer is not
the good start
and i i touched pyromancy and i didn't
have the greatest time
but that one takes that one's got a
specific style so everyone's told me
trickster devastator do those and then
try again and my time was very limited
so i knew i don't want to comment until
i
here's the thing i think they'll put
people off is
the story does have flavors of gears of
war
and i think if you take it too seriously
like
my first like an hour two hours like
this is
so trash and i was like rolling my eyes
and i'm trying to be nice and i'm like
i'm really trying to be nice and and i
don't again not to
you know cut you too much money it's um
the issue i was having at least on
console
is like the game is 60 but like the the
the
cutscenes and they're doing this weird
shift camera shack yep
oh and then the um the actual
conversation i was rolling my eyes a lot
of times
like oh my god what's going on yeah so
what changed them for me
is talk to me i was on the exact same
thing okay and then
there's a couple sections where
the writers make it very obvious they're
well aware that what they're writing is
complete
b grade daytime tv
trash right and they sort of break the
fourth wall and acknowledge it
okay okay i'm on board they're having
fun with it you know like
and that's the bit that changed for me
like i because i was sort of taking it
super serious like and because it does
it does have this serious overarching
art
it's kind of that way but then it's like
a b grey daytime
vampire you know
cw shows what we're leaning towards it
sounds like here
right and then and then they they had a
bit of fun with that i'm like fine i'm
on board
oh that that's a humor like i just
couldn't work out the tone until a
little bit later in the demo and then
i'm fine with it and uh yeah all the
camera shake you know
the the blur the camera the cutscenes
are all just
disgusting but um i honestly
if you just if you if you want to have a
good time on the demo just
skip all the cutscenes because i think
if you can just get to the rpg elements
and see if it's your jam and be like
okay i'll get it when it comes out
demos free and then then you can pay
attention to the story because they're
gonna
they're gonna remove camera shake and
blur and all that kind of stuff in the
in the in the
when it comes out so no i i trust you
judgment i judge you
because especially i think where you're
winning me over
is the fact that a you're not into the
third person
cover shooter kind of thing yeah i mean
so you came in
actually way more negative you know
because
yeah and for it to win you over that's
that to me now bodes well that
definitely i'm gonna give it a nice shot
and the reason why pyromancer is not the
best experience is because some of the
other class
like it sort of wants you to play half
cover shooter where the other classes
really want you to just chain abilities
and so
you basically don't even like the
devastator you don't even use cover and
that's what really
changes it for me okay is a little bit
more team-based
and ability-based and and it's hard to
chain it together as well as some of the
other classes
yeah yeah the technomancer is like the
the farthest range
probably most cover using you know
support class abilities your trickster
and your devastator
as as mylon said is like i you don't
want to be behind cover because you
literally get healed by being next to
people that's the whole purpose
oh okay hire a man so you have to tag
and then when they die
they die and it's like trying to figure
out the synergy of the abilities
and then when you get armor like some
blue armor even in the demo
will change up your abilities there was
one point i hadn't used for the
technomancers blighted rounds
hadn't used it that much all of a sudden
i got one every time i got a kill i got
30
of my ammo back when i finished i had an
extra magazine i'm doing 30
more damage all of a sudden i'm like a
technomancer feeling like a devas i'm
just mowing everybody down and i don't
run out of ammo and i was like
so the the rpg depth of what the mods on
the armor and then the big weapons can
do
the the how far you're going to be able
to go into builds in this thing
seems like it's got a lot of fun yeah
not a lot of potential to it yeah this
is good i'll definitely once
things settle down for me i'll
definitely welcome to the outriders
pogba
podcast baby i mean it's it's hard not
to
i mean they had what two million
downloads of the demo it's like it's
i think it's gonna be something that's
probably gonna fall at a good time in
april when all we really and destiny
probably have to look forward to is
guardian games
and i think that month of april is
probably very perfect for that audience
to say
i can take a little break and then
probably in about a month if you go hard
on it
it's it does have an end point probably
pat back pop back for the new season and
see how things wrap up so it's like it's
not a live stream
it's not a live service model i think
that's one of the greatest
i don't know if you watch skill up but i
think one of the
the the best points is it's very obvious
that the developers
have been paying attention to
this area this genre of loot and shoot
it's not a live service
um and the way that you gear up
and get loot and even like their
responses to loot cave you can see that
they've paid attention to how destiny
and bungie and
other games do patches and
do things with their community and how
they reward you for doing activities
like in just
previous games like i feel like anthem
you
when you actually started to get to the
the depth of it you're like
you guys haven't learned from all the
mistakes bungie made you haven't been
like paying attention um
and so yeah i i think that's what gives
me a little bit of hope
um and you know you can do the demo for
free and that
that shows a lot of confidence yep yeah
yeah that was like a demo it's not a
beta you don't have to pre-order it
it's an actual demo which is like
mind-boggling to me i'm like
huh yeah and your progress carries into
the game
you could literally be like and starting
on chapter two like
that just i think that was one thing i
said too is like there's a point like
why i was excited about the game
the depth the rpg the classes seem cool
but when they're like here's the game
this is everything that's in it it's
already baked in
you're not waiting for like patch one
patch two
it's basically done and then their
responsiveness as you said to the demo
they've already
patched the back end on the server
there's a patch coming with as you said
the motion blur to the demo they're
patching
and the demo doesn't have an end date
it's i don't know i've enjoyed it i'm
probably going to have a good probably
good solid month's worth of fun i've
already got way too many hours so i'll
shut up
yeah sorry should we hijack no no
i never know sometimes because this is
how we we run our podcast to you know we
just make a joke there'll be someone in
the comments who say podcast starts at
this time and
that's us we're tangent
but it's fun it's fun you got to have
stuff like that what i was going to say
um you know i want to get back to
obviously what you said earlier which is
you know you finding your way in content
creation you know
you kind of got that need she said okay
no one's doing laura and
and he stuck to it you've been killing
it what i wanted to really celebrate you
was was um what i considered like the
magic moment was
you know you being selected by bungie to
do like
the anthology you know what i'm saying
yeah and just being a part of that and
being
like tell me how that experience was for
you
and um just in general like do you
consider it like a magic moment for you
as a content creator yeah that's the law
i definitely think it was the pinnacle
moment
to be to to take something from like a
youtube channel to being
part of the franchise i guess
and to be involved with it um and it
came from the bible yeah
that's the one volume one i've got the
volumes behind me as well
um it came from the very first summit uh
so this would have been after d2
sort of crashed and burned and they held
the summit at the
studios in seattle and um
my name is wife i wasn't invited sucked
down
no no i'm
there's no way you and i can't be
friends you have to like talk and
compare notes and stuff like you guys
are
the like the two big people in lore that
i can honestly think of like
it's crazy there's no way you can't
there's no way you guys are cool
that was a good show that was good that
was good and
and vive's got a good sense of humor
there's a lot of banter between us so
it's it's fine
um so i went there so i was i was
probably the only person representing
law
at the summit and uh and there was two
days of workshops
with the developers from sandbox and pvp
and all this kind of stuff
this was before they re-added random
roles like this this is a level that
works
i was in i was in the meeting when
everyone's like we want random roles
back and the devs like gave in i'm like
okay
wow we'll do random roles again wow um
so at one point i got to the end of the
first day and sort of looked at the
jennifer the next thing
and i said to uh you can thank uh
patrick casey probably because this is
sort of all this is
this is a snowball that caused the
avalanche that sort of led to this
project i said man
where's that where's the law where's the
narrative because the narrative that you
remove the grimlock cards too right
so d2 was just the scannables
yeah so i'm like dude can we
can we talk to some people in narrative
and uh he pointed at christopher barrett
director and chris about notice there
was two people pointing at him and he
came
over and said hi and i said oh look um
love to talk to someone about
story and at that point i had done a
survey
uh 5 000 people completed it giving
feedback on
narrative so i had a basically a summary
document
of uh how to improve and uh he or
christopher barrett organized a meeting
with um
senior narrative lead and uh
outside of everything else so it was
just me oh
it was me oh no i'm gonna feel bad i
know
i've got their faces in my head i can't
remember the handles now um
doesn't matter
she was a crazy raid person i remember
her going to one there was three of us
and uh narrative team and christopher
barrett went through everything
um and a little once i got back to
australia
and a couple months later uh christopher
barrett called basically and said
hey we got an idea um thinking of an
anthology
uh do you do it i said sure
how do you how could you possibly say no
like
yeah and it was it was the the idea was
it was a
my role was to curate the series or to
curate a number of volumes
um to think about
how we could make a series where
you could read it well actually my goal
i had so much free i could do whatever i
really wanted to be honest they just
said the only instruction i got is we we
want you to put together volumes okay
that already exists
so i i themed
um actually a theme six books um looking
through
even though they just contacted me for
the first one i said well look i don't
want to put everything in the first book
because then you've got nothing to put
another book so
i sort of thought about what themes were
happening and what would be in each book
and um started to think about where you
would place grimball cards and even at
that point we didn't even have
uh like the the old school grandma cards
didn't have an order
yeah that's correct like so i was just
like going off theories of like what
you know the last word to after ghost of
last word after
a thorn so i was just putting it
together which i what i thought
would make not only chronological sense
but
um if you have no knowledge of law you
could read
volume oneness from start to finish and
follow a story and that was sort of my
goals is you could read the whole book
and it would read like a book
and you could read each chapter and each
chapter would be themed too maybe this
overarching
sort of narrative for each thing so you
know book one was
was dark mirror um and the symbolism of
that is that
uh what i wanted readers to think about
is are the hive any different from us
um would uh do we not do the same thing
that the hive do
and and that's why that book revolves
around the story of the hive and
how they tried to avoid their genocide
their journey and then
you know dark guardians and we go for
the same cycle
um and it ends with uh eris moore uh
giving us
and creating touch mouse which brings us
nice back to a loop of like
huh i guess we are like the hive
well some of them we may realize yeah
man yeah that
yeah and so it was definitely a pinnacle
it
surprisingly though you know bungie's
like any other company any other work
any
like the work i would say is not
typically fun because i just had to
re-read like
thousands of criminal cards and think
about like okay i've got a grimoire card
that's like
you know the old school stuff was like
shock blade from like
wielded by dredges i'm like is this
important
and if it is important and just do that
with every card and think about
is this important and is it if it is
important where should it sit
in relation to the entire series
and that is a pain in the butt i was
just about to ask you is it just the
giant bulletin board with strings going
everywhere what connects in what order
yeah in your it's a it's a little bit
like it obviously got easier and easier
because now they've got books right so
now
like i sort of broke the back of it with
volume one two and three because it
includes a lot of the original stuff
right
um and now that they have books like i
think eventually it probably would just
be a collection of their
law books now you don't need to change
it up you just need to decide what order
you want to put them in
um and you know that could be a little
bit confusing but
um yeah to go through the old stuff was
was challenging but
one of the really rewarding parts is
they also just
asked if i would give any direction
to the artist which was [ __ ] super
cool so like
i put little footnotes in uh
or comments on the on the drafts just
saying
people would love to see oryx vs akka
so i'll just highlight the the paragraph
that described it
and then basically like because it was
just me and the products team so it was
me
and like three other people and they
didn't have any background in
narrative law and and then eventually
when it was all sort of finalized it
went to narrative but
the most for the most working part it
was it was myself and the products team
who are more about
how we print this and and the logistics
of it and like an editor and stuff to
get the formatting and all that kind of
stuff right
and uh so i just had all this a lot of
freedom and volume on it anyway so
i think nearly all the images in volume
one were were things that i
recommended that i thought um players
would like
like you got a jaw like akka fighting
oryx you've got to draw the three
sisters
images um you've got to draw like one of
my favorite scenes is
is dredging you're being corrupted by
the witch you know so you've got the
titan sitting there with the witch over
the shoulder
whispering in his ear like there's so
many cool imagery uh
sections in there so yeah i just left
like footnotes like it would be cool if
you drew this and then like
the the artist is amazing they just wow
hit it out of the park
so yeah i did one two three so i haven't
been contracted past that
um that's pretty cool that is amazing um
just one two for them to trust you with
with that level
you know of um creativity and freedom
and then
you know also there there is some
pressure to that i listen to you say it
like
there's some pressure to it as far as
going through everything again curating
it
and then placement right and making sure
that things go cohesive and i love
what you said in reference to you know
being a fan of law yourself
there's those what we call those iconic
moments you know i'm saying
in destiny like you say with the sisters
we're dredging your the corruption
you know um oryx and and so many of that
stuff from taking king as well
and how it leads to now like i love how
you left those footnotes because
as destiny fans there's some moments
we'd like to see visually
because those are iconic moments so that
that's pretty cool yeah
the the really hard part for them was
like
they didn't want to burn themselves for
future content so for example like
if they draw korea blade transform
is that going to come up in the game in
five two three one year's time
right so
you know i wouldn't be surprised to be
honest if there if if some things are
changing the image is drawn the books
because it was done so long ago and
maybe they they decide they want to go
down a certain path
and you know now it's there but um
it's uh it was really cool being able to
see that come to life and
i don't think i honestly don't think and
i think this is
um christopher barrett that probably
really
had my back in that scenario was
i think he just sort of because this was
like in the worst time of destiny
it was bad i remember that something
yeah i remember
when we started our podcast actually
which is probably yeah curse of osiris
we started we were flashpoint at that
point yeah before we became the last
word
yeah and i feel like he he slid under
the radar as sort of like this small
project which is why it was just sort of
contracting me everything was already
written right so all the all so it's
basically like you know it was a bit of
a
it wasn't a huge risk because every the
writers all the stuff was there they
just need someone to put it together
right this is like and it was adapted by
milan
yeah and then it was like i they
100 undressed no matter how many copies
i would sell
they would sell and as soon as volume
one released and they sold out like
twice or three times or something
the team obviously grew so then it was
me and another gent
uh working on volume two and three nice
i got they got into some other old
school dudes to um
help curate it and and theme it and and
go from there and i think the
i mean that's why volume one's such a
safe safe i mean you can't go wrong with
the books sorry do you know what i mean
like it's
fire it's it's it's it's a very safe
volume to open with which was also the
plan
yeah oh no like random question for seth
somebody told me to ask marbles hobbit
destiny
halo does that make any sense to you
right so around the same time that i
started
on the journey of trying to think of
content to make and how to diversify and
i guess i'm the kind of person who is
very deliberate in the content that i
make
um and
i like to plan that and think about the
entertainment value
that it might bring to a stream or a
youtube channel and
to the point where i probably overthink
it and talk myself out of
out of doing stuff and because halo was
so
instantly successful streaming it and it
was like i
didn't plan it i didn't think about it
it just i just did it
so i took that mind sounds like you know
what i'm just gonna do stuff
and um i think someone pressured me
or said do marvel's race um
so we did a marbles race and i thought
well we've got to give you something
right and
when i'm very first started streaming
every time someone subscribed i used to
tell them a lore story
and like improv so they would just give
me a topic
and i would tell them the story so
they'd say oh i love shacks
okay so i'd use that username and i'd be
like i'll tell a story and it would be
like the story of
how shax broke his horn and it was this
person right that had a fight
they snapped his horn off this is the
unknown law
so i'll do that so i thought all right
well we'll do a marbles race
and whoever wins i'll tell you a story
and similar to halo it ended up being
like just the most random thing and it
was like people love it so we've been
we've basically got a book and i have it
transcribed now it's electronic book
um and i think we're up to like 300
pages of
just custom stories like marvel universe
kind of
just there's halo there's and i use a
lot of the ring soundtrack because i
love
all the rings so i actually every every
person starts off as a
as a hobbit because i
i was i was making fun of my own
subscribers saying that like
they're all these like absolute massive
lore nerds lore hobbits are like
sort of come in hunched over to the
stream like
you know so i did this skit where i was
wearing like a hood and stuff and just
ended up being this joke about
all my nerdy subscribers being law
hobbits you know these underground
caves dwelling tell us the law and this
is a long story so everyone starts off
this fictional world and uh yeah we've
we've had people embrace the darkness we
have people
piloting pyramid ships different people
beach shacks we have
and and we it's a bit like dungeons and
dragons now this is sort of universe
we've been building um
that's awesome so it's it's awesome yeah
yeah it's it's pretty fun so that's what
he's talking about
it's destiny shout out to aaron kill
with the awesome question
cognito what's the question
that was the one yeah no that was a
great question eric yeah salute derek
kelvin
he's hilarious yeah man i mean two
things um you know i'm a big
i i feel that's my opinion like now i
feel like the uh
narrative has been in a good place and
they're going in the right direction
in game right and this is one of the
things i know the destiny community's
not happy
for the most part with certain things of
the game and you know the grind aspect
and the reward structure we know what's
wrong right we know the trial stuff but
the thing
i think doesn't get enough credit as i
feel for the first time
they've been they've had this nice
narrative flow
usually going from season in in you know
from from one
one piece of content to another and i
want to know your opinion like do you
feel
narratively at this point that bungie's
in a better place you know i'm saying
from a continuity
to telling the stories and um just in
general especially now what's going on
season to chosen yeah you know kyle
you know this whole thing because the
last point i'll say is that you know
for me and i i will i will die on this
grave be a potassium without it but uh
but he actually he agrees with me
is that i forgot what season it was but
it was a season that we learned
you know um when it was uh shax osiris
um saint 14 and it was the devil's ruin
quest and we got this great audio lore
and that's when we learned about um shaq
singing the song that ends up being an
evil song when you know as far as song
of sabbath
and stuff like that but it was those
type of interactions and what i like
that they're doing
like when you see the kyle season of the
chosen stuff and we have now crow
or um saladin or all these different
major players
narratively you know using voice actors
and and telling the story
pushing it that way do you feel this is
a good direction for them or do you feel
like hey
you know it's still room for a pool how
do you feel narratively destiny right
now i'm just gonna i'm just gonna pop in
and say that's definitely not a leading
question
leading you leading the witness here a
little bit well i mean
i prefaced it by saying my opinion is
but then what do you think you're what i
think it is
um i think beyond light
got it um pretty spot-on
okay um because they introduced a lot of
voice acting and dialogue i think
there's a huge portion of people that
skip through
text and i still think there's a huge
portion that's
obviously of the story that's hidden so
you have to have other mechanisms to
tell a story
um destiny i don't think will ever be
the pinnacle of in-game storytelling
however they do a really good job at
placing things for you to find if you
are interested
later i think the main issue
with destiny is well it's not even an
issue it's a discussion point
and that is accessibility is it okay to
have a game that you have to go and read
a book to really know what's going on
like is that and that's what i think
that's what destiny
probably is right now like if you don't
go
consume youtube content on the law
or you don't read quite a hefty part of
text you probably don't know what really
is happening
and so it's not necessarily a bad thing
because a lot of people dig that because
it provides opportunity
to enjoy their game whilst not playing a
lot of people read
grim all cards read lore tabs on their
lunch break
they'll listen to a youtube video whilst
right
people listen to my videos whilst
driving to work on the train on the bus
so
like and they get to experience destiny
while they're not playing and then when
they get home and they do play then
their experience is enhanced because
they understand some of the story
but the discussion point still is
do you like that are you okay with that
right because i don't think
we're gonna get the
that you know that narrative in gamers i
think i think the big release is like
beyond light i think beyond light was
was a reasonable story to follow but the
real juice was in deep stone crypts
you know the online campaign was all
about aramis and
it was a fine story right um it was a
fine
campaign but the real meat potatoes was
deep stone crypt and clovis brian you
couldn't get hold of that unless you
read the collector's edition
so how do people feel about that and i
think that's the that's probably more of
the discussion than
uh than anything else
how are you feeling about this um
so the irony is i need it to be
difficult because that that's what's
that's what makes my channel successful
that's irony right
yeah because people come to the channel
because
they don't know what's going on
everything is laid out in game you're
like why do i need to be here
that's a good point yeah that's artist
yeah i
really enjoy title coming back i think
drip fed story loses a lot of momentum
and i think
people lose they lose the passion to
follow the story along when it's
once per week you get this story segment
and especially when the story segment i
mean these segments we're getting uh
holograms with a bit of voice over and
mostly text
um so i think it's i do think it's hard
to keep people engaged in a season
like that with a drip fed story so i
don't think it's at
how good it could be running right now
and i especially think
when people fall away becomes even
harder
and i sometimes think that the drip fed
stuff is also pushing people a little
bit away
and so like i i stepped away for good
two weeks i'm like i have no [ __ ]
idea what's going on
and i'm meant to be the lord dude right
and i stepped away for like a couple
weeks and i
i don't i don't understand where where
carter lives and what's going on and
actually i do because i read the law but
if i didn't if i hadn't read the book
then i'll be like huh
what's happening here
e yeah uh i think i i don't think
they've got
my i my overarching thought on story is
this
i think that they should have
a yearly narrative arc
you know let's say the curse in the
dreaming city okay i don't think that
should still be left unresolved
when forsaken came out i think there
should be an expectation we're
introducing this plotline
each season might go off on a slight
tangent but it will contribute back to
it
and not only this you know there's the
the franchise arc
and then there's like what i would like
to see is a franchise arc and then like
12-month arc
yep and then all the seasons of the
rivers that feed into everything
and so yeah we might go fight a vex but
it should feed back in this idea of the
curse
and so every season when you pick it up
it's it's giving you a little bit more
information
and then eventually boom you actually
get a like a conclusion to it
and then you move on and then the next
big september release comes out and you
get the next big
12-month arc right and
people can understand what's going on i
feel like
bungie has started many many 12-month
arcs that have just remained
remained yeah unresolved yeah and i
think that
people lose motivation to try to keep up
with it
um and
yeah that's why channels do so well
uh no i mean for me i said like i've
been
things like hey i've always wanted like
an armor 3.0 for a while and now
transmog is going to exacerbate the need
for that
um i mean you mentioned yeah there's
issues with the game sure we still love
the game we're crazy passionate about it
the piece that does me have intrigued
though is the long
term as you said those 12-month what is
now we know the light versus dark saga
how that's going to culminate with
lightfall and the unknown expansion
but also as mylan said for me the part
that burns me is
the it's like i get one page of a book
every week in the mail
and i literally cannot get it any faster
and you could as i mean there's lore to
go in and read and now with like
the pieces that we're getting out of the
glycon ship and knowing what callus is
trying to commune with all the darkness
stuff and it's just like
there's some craziness going on but also
again if i just be like hey here's this
cool like
dead man's tail and i got my gun i don't
really care about the catalyst though
it's a
scout rifle there's so much people miss
in there
and it's just the depth of like what
callus is trying to do
commune with the darkness kind of went
in and then you got the ship floating
back out i
don't know if i still don't actually
know if callus is
completely dead but might be so you know
i'm sure you could probably answer that
maybe well that's something i i can't
really that's what i'm going to work on
today
yeah that that's what that's what i'm
going to work on today actually is i
want to
sort of bring that up as a topic um
because i think there's there's some
interesting stuff to talk about
with with callus in that book
um i sometimes think about
if i wanted to improve narrative
or at least i think accessibility i
think to story
more than improve narrative because you
know whether you like a story or not
it's very subjective but
i think it's more objective to think
about how people access it
and i think um
what would make my channel be less
relevant which would make it
more relevant to people story-wise i
just
i would love for a playlist and this is
so much work and so much money but
i would love for you to be able to go
into the audio options
drop everything down select the law book
and they've got you know i mean i'd love
steven fryden to rate it
they've got someone right and you go you
know what i want to listen
just like a codex in like a mass effect
or whatever oh you just stopped
doing it i was just about to fight it
that i hate to cut you because you're on
fire right now
that is why mass effect is beloved
because of the codex and then you you re
and you
learn about the racist through a
narrator and in certain different points
continue milan you on fire
one people do that i mean just imagine
right that you could write that you
could
make a custom playlist of narrated
law pages or law books whilst you do
your bounties
because i feel like that is how people
consume
youtube content in destiny and in
general that's how they play destiny
i feel like people do they they do their
daily destiny dishes
and they hang out with mates and they
talk [ __ ] or they put a youtube video on
the background and i think if you want
to make law more accessible
you know no not everyone i know it seems
odd but not everyone can read either
do you know what i mean like it's it i'm
sure that is an issue for people to
engage in the story and
uh it'd be cool to just have like i
would do it
yeah i would listen to it it would
improve my my experience
because you know sometimes i read things
only once and i i don't quite get it
get the contest they slowly like started
if they could use like the
uh you could honestly as bungie like put
those out as like a podcast too
because i mean as you're saying to like
take the audio but if they already have
the voice lines anyway
go make them accessible out of the game
too as you said if you want to drive
around and be like i want to hear about
you know kyle's book that's going on
this then just pop it in your car
something like that like
i feel but yeah i'm i will say one thing
with beyond light i did
really like it's like the idea of
listening to the book the books that are
in game
i couldn't think of a better way that's
like perfect the one other piece i
really did like that beyond light did
that i haven't seen much of except
probably went from destiny 1 to destiny
2 is the bit of storyboard kind of
animated storyboard is the best way i
can describe it
when you go and it's showing kind of
more the history of the fault
that yeah the way they did that oh like
throw those in bits and places now i
don't know how expensive
and how hard they are to create because
i know artists can do it but it could
still be more
you know sketchy like done in sketch
sket
yeah done is more of a sketches like a
full render
um i i think that that
i actually put that as i actually said
that to
the narrative i said send us some
feedback i was like i think these
are a great use of resources because
they
i i they can't be too expensive because
gamma trap and i did one for a promo and
it took us like two days
okay like exactly it's
yeah you can you can do it you know it's
literally
charcoal um paintings
but you know digital charcoal painting
it's just an effect they're using
with like ink blots after effects with
voiceover
the voiceover is probably the most
expensive part like i would say
even did that we then we like right with
the legends tales
it goes to shishiba yeah yeah same thing
yeah
those were so because you got like a l
you got so much more depth on those
like the tails the way they did it it
didn't take that long you got a cool
idea and you're like
now i know what's going no that piece
when they did that and beyond light
stuck out so much as something
of they could explain maybe they do that
stuff towards the end of the season like
once we get the full story of what's
going on with the glycon
you know and maybe it unlocks in the
game you can be like hey here's the
history of this ship and you could go
watch two minutes or whatever it
wouldn't take that long to be like this
is what happened they went in here
callous messed up tried to talk pop back
out kind of dead we
like whatever it is like that wouldn't
take too long and somebody could be like
hey do you want to know the history of
this
here's a quick storyboard thing cool
like that's
in game i think would do and they
wouldn't have to go as you said the lore
books that you do
obviously because i want you to keep
your job like that
deep type stuff like still takes a
little bit more effort but some of like
the higher end stories of what's
currently going on
i think that'd be a nice way to keep
some people a little a little bit more
informed
well i think i think like this is sort
of what i'm saying before is it's the
accessibility and i think
i think resources should go into
those hooks how do you hook people into
wanting to dig deeper because once
you've got them hooked on that
your job everything else is already
there like all the deep lore is there
all the books already there
but i feel like one of the areas of
missing is like how do you hook people
in i think
those little cut scenes those charcoal
paintings with the ink you know blotches
are a great
hook you know more voice acting is is a
great way to get people involved
absolutely give me a playlist
where i can have it read it to me now
i'm like because once it's read you
well then you're going to go seek
information because you don't get the
answer yet you just you get the
information becomes available and now
it's like all right how do i actually
you're either going to start piecing it
together yourself and talking to friends
about it or you're going to go start
watching videos or you're going to start
being on forums or reddit or whatever i
agree i agree
yeah yeah i'll let you go because i know
time's limited i don't want to i could i
could go crazy right now when i'm done
i feel like we're just having if you got
one go just off the top of your head
just yeah he's on fire just your
personal um
you know favorite characters in the law
or just moments where you felt
dave executed really well
like a top three top three lord moments
list is that what you're trying to get
out there
i i always struggle with this i i feel
like um
i feel like when i write a law script
it's always my favorite law script for
the time
because yeah it's what you're most fresh
into
you dove into that yeah
and then i'm like i hate it because i
spend you know an entire day or two days
and i i must have some sort of wipe in
my memory and i just
get rid of it and i'm like huh what did
i say
people quote me i don't remember saying
that i don't know
um
i honestly like i i'll need to open up
my videos and have a look
like i said before i think um some of
the scenes that really stand out i do
think is some of the the dredging
uh dredging your corruption with the
with the um
with the light and the wizards sort of
whispering in his ear was one of the
things that i i really
enjoyed um
keep talking let me bring let me bring
up some stuff i knew i should work i
knew this
you know what that's the the the
creation of touch of malice is also
uh a really cool one uh that i really
enjoyed i think
the delivery of touch of malice was uh
i liked the idea of exotics being
interwoven into this overarching plot
and then you get given it at the end and
it just
makes it seem that much more powerful
and i think touch malice is
probably the greatest exotic in regards
to law yeah maybe you've got thorn
and la thorne like you know they've got
those trilogy of like d1 guns that like
yeah they're just so cool and
i don't know if anything's come as close
to them gala horn
you think about gala horn touch malice
thorne last word like they were just so
interwoven to so many stories that it's
like
yeah enough those are good choices those
are good choices yeah
yeah uh what are your favorite ones
you tell me yeah maybe i can criticize
it i'll let you start then i'll go
art of it is just when you go back to
i guess for me the fact that i haven't
ever gotten into lore as much
in a lot of things just because i
haven't spent seven years with a whole
lot of things
so getting into it's like the more
you're like okay i want to know a little
bit more i want to go get the history
and when you get in truly like
the what the hive started as
to become to work with the worm gods to
just almost the creation of the hive the
depth that
for one that bungie put into it but also
even just when i think back it's like i
have this weird special place for like
crota's end raid just because
thematically it fits the hive and like
the
kind of frenetic nature to them and then
when you go learn more about them you
kind of understand more about the power
vacuum that happened in oryx and
there's so much there for me it's always
been like the hive have been cool
the darkness and theory is cool just
don't know a damn thing about him yet
but
um and then honestly recently it's been
like the almost the polar opposite of
kaidel being a
not a partner in all of this but
not not gall like the opposite of gaul
to see that like
somebody who's willing to talk and aim
guns but then not fire and back off
and then it's like the same thing you
dig and you realize what happened to
their world when you get a little more
so there's just some cool like the the
enemy races is like yeah we're guardians
we have kind of a cool history but like
the enemy races both the cabal as i've
learned a lot more this season which has
been really fantastic because i feel
like they've been
under under misunderstood i guess
and then but just the depth of the hive
are both my two probably yeah
no absolutely i think um yeah for me
i i think peak storytelling for me is
probably like uh
forsaken as far as um just from
the introduction to the dreaming city
the lore with that riven
and um basically a culmination of all
these different
you know destiny iconic lore figures
that we knew about we knew about almond
car and stuff like that but
to actually see one and then the curse
and then the shattered throne the
ascendant room i
i think and visually the way they
displayed it in the game the aesthetic
of it you know i mean all of those
things coming
together and for me which i was wanting
to ask you earlier was that
my forsaken is it ranked so high for me
is that i love that cohesiveness
narratively right when you do the
campaign
and then that transitions into the raid
and we have a reason
as to why we're going into it king
probably did that best as far as wise
going into with oryx
but um what i felt where forsaken then
take it a step further is
okay first time you beat a boss and then
okay now we're delivering we have to
take riven's heart
out to do the queen's walk and stuff
like that and then the cycle of the
curse
and then the the world being affected
afterwards right
so you know they didn't resolve that
part yet but
but i do like the fact that it was just
cohesiveness that
narratively you know you went through it
and i think that to me is them
probably at that best so it kind of
broke my heart when they said that you
know we're not gonna ever get
anything like forsaken size again yeah i
agree
i think forsaken is pretty close to like
the blueprint of a
if they resolve the dreaming city like
six months later through
like um the seasons i think that would
be
the blueprint for how to deliver
not only gameplay but story raids how
it all ties in exotics all that kind of
stuff um
couple other so i just had a quick look
to my videos let's go let's go just
recently banshee 44 was super cool
that was good that was good yes yes
tied to an amazing exotic um and
answered
sort of this age-old question of why is
banshee's memory so
rubbish really nice really nice
that's a great great um clove
i i think they did an amazing job with
clovis bray
and deep stone crypt i think um
we always knew they were a dodgy company
and um a a
big corporation just manipulating and
doing whatever they want and i think i
did a really cool job with painting a
a picture of um you know
if we were into if we had multiple plans
that we lived on there would be a big
corporation like clovis bray doing some
dodgy ass [ __ ] on like
new roblox uh and i think they got that
really
well done um clovis bray's a great
villain
oh he's amazing i love the voice act and
i love um
his narration well the ai the crypt ai a
narration during the raid
of him you know like when you're
infiltrating like do you realize you're
infiltrating the great
you know clovis bray you you know like
you guys don't realize what you're doing
he's gonna stop at anything to protect
his science and all the shady dodgy
stuff that he's been doing on this space
station but continue
yeah yeah so i love uh
and then finally i think one of the best
fight scenes in destiny was uh
felwinter versus shacks from memory i
think it was shacks
uh telling the bit of the backstory of
the iron lords and how uh
is it was it was filled with shacks
right it was shaft i remember
winter pretty sure i can't even remember
now i remember
damn i'm trying i'm messing up that
because it was a fight i'm trying to
remember that this is when we discovered
the whole
he was in essentially uh rasputin
son and and raspberry was tracking him i
just i can't remember specifically if
the fight was shax
because it's been a while since i read
it i'm pretty sure shaq's knocked fell
into his head off multiple times and it
was one of the best fight scenes ever
um there are some more recent more
recent examples
good news that's good great stuff
brother great stuff
got him ah you got one go
no i mean i i pretty much went with that
um as far as
what you got as far as um you know i
should have checked
shaq's beheading him like 53 so yeah
yeah yeah the chat agrees yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah for sure for sure backhanded
his face off jama trap did some really
cool art of uh
shacks just doing this backhand and just
ripping off phil winter's head
it was
here's a good time to this because out
riders is
without bringing it right back to
outriders outriders is not t for teen
right and yeah i've all and
destiny is in gameplay sense is
and um but the law obviously isn't and
it i've always felt that
the the the rating system has held
destiny back
and playing outright has really reminded
me oh this is what gore looks like
this is what like when you destroy an
alien there's blood and guts everywhere
and
i feel like destiny has such darkness to
it but it just doesn't come through
good point in the game because they're
t15 yeah i kind of forget how much
blood my shotguns have caused to pop all
over my screen
the tricks are when it uses its slow
bubble you do your temporal blade and
you're just watching all these body
pieces and rib cages slowly break apart
it's kind of beautiful
and like just you know a symphony of
destruction as you watch it all go down
and then the bubble goes away and all
goes just like and it's hilarious
because
in that moment you're like it's been a
while since i've seen this type of thing
because i mean even like you shoot like
a fallen and they kind of like whisper
away and they all have their little
specific deaths but there's not a lot of
blood and guts hardly at all if any in
the game that i can honestly think of
intentionally as you said
if it's teen it's not a good point
about that he's absolutely right and
that that could hold you back creatively
yeah it's interesting how they don't get
pulled up they can almost
write whatever they want and it doesn't
impact the rate like
i mean the books of sorrow is a story of
genocide like do you know like yeah it's
it's it's interesting how they can be so
dark in the writing
and and it be fine um
maybe the writing guys have not actually
read any of the
they're not gonna get that far we'll
pass the ratings that's fine guys just
put whatever you want in there
yeah yeah yeah um so yeah just another
another interesting sort of
thought experiment for playing uh
outriders especially especially with the
writing you know there's lots of
swearing and stuff
yeah in the dialogue which uh
i always felt like d1 was a bit bit more
gritty
yeah in regards to just a visually and
when dj came out i had this like
overwash overwatch like polish to it
it's sort of like a sheen a little bit
of the grit
yeah little bit yeah yeah yeah
yeah so i wanted to actually ask you as
when the state of the game dropped
obviously we know about the delay for
which queen
um i guess it's a two-part question so
we'll get ready
one is the fact that there's the quote
from one of the game directors saying
savithun's setting up her dominoes and
then zevorath is trying to mess with us
right now
is there anything you can even like have
an idea or what would you like to see
from savithoon coming into the game that
would be satisfactory to
you the way she's built and built up as
a character and then the second piece to
continue past that
as the light light and darkness saga has
kind of a culmination in year 10
we don't know the name of good point
where would you
where do you where would you like to see
this game get to
slash or are there certain things you
want to you want to make sure you see
happen if that makes sense
cool i'll start with the second one the
light in the dark saga because
this is really super interesting because
that's that to me is the end that's the
overarching
narrative arc so what what could
possibly be after
like this is dark and i'm either
skeptical that we'll get a proper
resolution
because i mean we saw
like we're halfway there too like we've
embraced the darkness now
yeah so how do you concur
i i sort of feel like for destiny to
keep going on
the light versus dark overarching story
needs to remain i mean the fact that
they're talking about concluding it
like i would have thought that the
conclusion of light versus dark
is this is the end of destiny right
so a lot of people would have thought
that
what comes after that because okay then
well you know maybe that's what we're
working towards because because now that
we've embracing light and dark
there's not a need to get rid of one
right the whole message so far is you
can have balance
yeah um and that they're they're equal
parts of the same coin so you know why
remove one force because then there
won't be
balance essentially um and so it comes
down to having enemies
do similar things and wield light and
dark powers
against us so you know that that could
be
where they're they're heading and the
theory sir but i don't i don't i don't
know why you would
i i am honestly confused about
mentioning
light and dark saga because i just in my
mind that's just
that's that's the destiny franchise i
was like what destiny is right yeah
i mean that started the stranger and
all the questions of the traveler now we
know a little bit that the pyramids
exist we've seen them
obviously they took over part of you
know the sol system
i'm that's i that's what has wanted me
the almost the most intrigued to know
that
i'm gonna be with this franchise for
years because in my head i want to know
where it goes
because i'm so intrigued to know how we
get from where we are
where we've dabbled in the darkness
which didn't have too many ramifications
yet
lightfall by name even if it's just a
filler name
the theory behind light fall losing
light maybe actually being a thing is
that real i don't know
right but yeah it's like that's they've
built such an intriguing world it's like
the fact that it's three years out i'm
like i just want to know right now but
obviously of course no that that's
that's great i mean um i agree
like the the light versus dark side good
that's been the overarching theme
you know as far as what we just know for
what destiny is so to hear them say
like you know mylon said the conclusion
of the light versus dark saga yeah
it definitely you know raises questions
okay so where the hell do you go
after this because this seems to be the
foundation of what
is built on yeah i mean unless it's just
the pyramid chips right unless they're
just talking about the pyramid ship
conclusion
because we haven't really got an answer
to that like
they're just invaded and like whole
planets disappeared
right and then we embraced the darkness
and there was sort of in this
window yeah we're like we embrace the
darkness we're fine
some of the planets are not out there
and then obviously callus you'll have to
let us know what he ended up finding or
how that experiment went
but it's yeah it's it
but that's also kind of the thing that
destiny tends to do is
hey we lost part of the planets in the
solar system to the quote destiny
content vault which is fine
but also we there's not been a mention
of like
hey somebody go on a scouting mission
what's it look like what happened
nothing
so unless it's unless it is out there
and i don't know it but it's just so
weird that
at the end of the i'm crapping on yours
now at the end of year
three for destiny 2. is that right yeah
at the end of year three for destiny 2
we're like hey the darkness invaded the
solar system map
here's the new director no mention of it
that's some of those times where as you
said the
the lore and the story in destiny is
like just killing me
because such a big event happens and
then they're like well go to europe and
check out aramis and i'm like what about
the other big big giant thing that just
happened
yeah you've gotta wait a while yeah and
that that's sort of why i was
saying things before about
having a plan a 12-month plan to
to resolve you know storylines that that
open
and you can still have these overarching
ones that come through but um
to keep the momentum of what they're
sort of saying
yeah yeah no absolutely absolutely yeah
i think that's it
it's it's an interesting dynamic you
know we got to see where they go with it
i do like the fact that for the first
time we're getting
those um what i call see i would say
like a playbook
because i felt in the past we
narratively they wouldn't tell us
hey this this year we're doing this and
this year you know this one's with queen
and this one's light falling
you know so on and so forth so you know
that that's a start and um
yeah it was it was definitely a surprise
to me when i even heard them mention
that so i'm curious and then the other
thing i would like to know
you know if we ever get the introduction
of another alien race just to you know
add the flavor into it because obviously
there's a lot of stories that we've been
we've already been told
yeah yeah cabal we've getting followed
you know
we've gotten you know hive it's been
there and i'm very curious
you know if that's something that will
ever be reachable
quote-unquote the darkness race like the
you know all these rumors that we've
heard for the years like
i would love to
to have a new race added and i think for
a long time people were waiting for it
to happen and it just sort of never
eventuated
and uh i don't think i think the
standard form that will be
adapt to modify the models we already
have which are the cabal
hive vex
and f4 what's the fourth one i'm sorry
good brain's gonna fry that's fine
you're good you're good yeah yeah i i i
you know they do have quite a bit of
flex you know we've seen
severe fallen we've seen darkness fall
and you know
um i would like for it to change
it would definitely freshen up just like
new supers freshen up the game
having something new to shoot would also
freshen up the game yes but
i don't really feel like they're they
can do anything with with any of the
enemies
right now and give them whatever powers
they want they just got to make up some
reason for them to have it
and they can change mechanics and they
can do different stuff um
i would love to see something different
but i i don't feel like it's going to
happen
um unless that that is a plan
after lightfall do you think it would be
more possible with the introduction of a
destiny 3 as opposed to the plan to
continue
destiny on this path of same engine same
do you feel that might be necessary to
facilitate that
i think um oh the whole
i feel like destiny should get rid of
numbers and just be destiny
and it's a live service model like
world of warcraft and it just it just
keeps on going i guess
it might need a reason i feel like
they're pretty close to everyone
being on the same page with next gen
console and pc and crossplay like i feel
like they're pretty close it's sort of
just a little i i never really felt like
destiny got out of its teenage years and
knew what knew who it was
do you know and became a daughter this
is what we are this is what we can
produce
right this is what to expect i feel like
they've always been
playing experimenting or we tried this
model we've tried this model and never
really found their feet and i'm sort of
just waiting for them to go you know
what
this is that what you expect this wasn't
any season or in fact you know we can't
put this out every season you're going
to get it every six months and
or and that's what it is and we've got
heaps of loot
you get the big story plus the big story
plots on the on the septembers
get a little bit of story throughout
that and and just sort of i don't feel
like they've got they're sort of close
to their formula
yeah i don't feel like they've like the
confidence to do that yep this is it
this is what we've got yeah i don't know
if that's just like
playing on the community because the
community i've just got so much hope
about
it yeah it's like oh okay this could be
it this could be the accent
no no how about this no no no no
no that's i mean that that's a good
point because sun setting is the prime
example of
you read my mind i was just about to go
there yeah i mean but it's such a
substantial decision that had
such large ramifications blow back from
the community
and then to turn around on it so fast
like we talked about this yesterday and
last week with travis
it's so big that i know they're a very
data-driven planning company obviously
they literally wrote like 10 years on
the whiteboard all that stuff so there's
planning involved
but then of course it's like the
execution or
they didn't expect things to go quite
however things go as you said it's like
they're still
trying to figure this stuff out and i
think as you said and i've
keep kind of harping on i would rather
see a bigger
kind of like you said do an expansion
whenever they release it
they can take the time now they're not
forced to be in the hall in you know
september november
do whatever the witch queen expansion is
which we'll get back to in a second
and then maybe six months later it's
like this is the second piece to kind of
keep the live service going it's got a
bigger chunk to it
bigger amount of loot that they can put
in they've got a little more time to
develop as you said
brings a little more to the story that
they already tried to get through in the
first half
and then they can kind of alternate in
six months maybe to keep the live
service going but the three-month model
with the way the stories go sometimes
it's like we're going here we go
straight off come back and
okay we're still some of this some of
the seasons feel like
kind of unnecessary tangents to fill
space as opposed to
building towards like your forsaken
narrative in the dreaming city
you had season of the drifter right
could not have felt like so far apart so
it's like it's
i like that idea of a through line of 12
months
however you do the timing but make that
story continue to build
i i don't mind learning about other
characters but somehow you got to tie it
back in
but i wanted to kind of get back and ask
you when it comes to just this coming
year like
it's going to get delayed for sabbath
and they're trying to do
bigger overarching kind of arcs and
narratives and things with characters
they said
what do you what do you what do you want
to see out of which queen when it comes
to that expansion do you
is do you have any expectations any
characters that you want to see that you
may know about that most of us probably
don't
what are your hopes for that one i think
sabathune has
pretty big issues to fill um
with oryx obviously uh taking
king has huge nostalgia
for a lot of veteran players and
probably considered one of the
greatest stories combined with raid
combined with campaign
probably with the exception of forsaken
that's probably happening right
um at the very least a conclusive story
yeah um it is hard
to do something i think the issue with
sabbath it's hard to do something
different because she's obviously hive
and she fun well actually maybe this is
how they're doing it
you know to kill the hive we've got to
go to the throne world which is a whole
story of taking king
it's in the throne well it's on the
dreadnought it's the merging of
realities it's that was the right that's
how we defeated oryx once and for all
sabathune is trying to escape the worm
god through trickery
through this so it's starting to set her
up
in a position where we maybe don't have
to go into throne world or at least we
go into a singularity or we go into a
wormhole or
i think that they're trying to open that
door and move a little bit away from
traditional sort of hive mechanics so
they can play a little bit more with
with the raid and with the story so i
think sabbath you know in her nature
could go
anywhere and they've done a good job in
setting that up
um i do think
sh it's going to have to be pretty
spectacular to beat
the story of oryx and i think that is
probably going to be a pretty
high expectation in the destiny
community and we've already seen
how this plays out with worm gods and
strike missions
please don't do that don't do it don't
do it
nocris
they're very well aware of that and i
hope they're they just look like you
know
we've got to do justice to this uh it's
got to come back to the dreaming city
and the curse
in some way and how that's going to be
resolved
do you think we defeat her
like do we want oh
i i don't like who's left after that
who leads a hive after that you think
about like what things they've got in
the pipeline
what how do they how do they keep
pushing the hive or do they put the hive
in the back burner
like maybe we do maybe this is the end
of the heart this is the end of the hive
yeah
maybe this is maybe this because it
would have to be right because there's
no
there's other people with so much
history in their story
you don't have to restart for us to care
about anything
yeah it seems like related yeah i mean
we've we got the tease of zebra wrath in
season of the hunt
i don't know if that's gonna be as she's
one of the three sisters i feel like she
got
kind of a small dose for being yeah not
quite on probably the same level as the
other two but she's still
fairly substantial i don't know if she's
going to be something in maybe season 15
to lead into savithoon but i was like
i'm with you it's like
as it is such a kind of one of the final
major
pieces on the board for the hive
i would be curious what they do with the
race after that's a fair i never thought
about like
if you do defeat or like what do you do
with the hive are they still
compelled to do like who fills the power
vacuum so what's the word you'll
probably know how to say is
quaria like the vex hive who is that
do you know who i'm talking about i know
yeah yeah korea yeah yeah it's
blade transform transform yeah yeah
so she was the um
when crota got tricked
to cutting a whole a portal
into oryx's throne world and the vex
invaded oryx's throne world and he's
like oh
crap and then oryx came along started
taking everyone
captured correa blade transform gifted
it
to sabathune as part of
you know the hive uh mentality you know
we love each other by killing each other
yeah
cool you've given me a vex system that's
probably gonna try
you know kill me um and there's a whole
bunch of other i can't remember at the
moment there's a whole bunch of
other stuff that's that's sort of been
hinting especially the forsaken
and the curse people are gonna freak out
people know in the comments let's go oh
that's right tolan says something in
about choreo blade transform
comment what it is chat my new red to
put it in yeah you're right
on top of the lord too he's one of those
that's pretty into it
but it was like there's there's only as
you said like i don't know if that
if that could be a way to tie into like
vex for lightfall if the darkness still
plays in more
i just always wonder about some of those
final pieces after savithoon cause
as you said she has probably the biggest
shoes in the game to fill
so the expectations are massive but then
where it goes that's what kind of blows
me away sabithoon feels like the
culmination of so much now
i still don't know too much about
marisov and what she's up to but
sabathun is such a big thing
lightfall feels like it's in the wrong
place to be after that because sabathune
feels like what would be a big ending to
something like this so i'm still
intrigued to know where it all goes yeah
definitely yeah yeah man we got we got a
lot of chapters that we got to figure
out man
we do man we gotta be respectful of time
i know our brother is uh
got some things constraints and stuff
like that so we are respectful but
turned it into a larp so i mean i
wouldn't have it any other way with this
man
either way yeah yeah an out writer's law
episode how's that
yes yes yes the outright is the law
episode
oh look look i i say to everyone like
because obviously everyone's nagging me
do halo law as well right i'm like
dudes i'm not reading two decades of
law for a video that you know
how many halo books are there oh i
couldn't tell you there's probably way
too many at this point
you know like that that ship has sailed
um
and uh i i've yeah whenever i play a new
game you gotta do law on it and i feel
like um
you know still trying to diversify and i
think if i can
uh move to some other topics it would be
a nice
a nice change of nice for spice in my
life
to not spend my days reading and writing
just screaming at people and screaming
at the games
so outside of video games for one last
question from me
as you know they've kind of restructured
bungie a little bit brought on like
execs for tv companies and stuff like
that
what format would you like to see them
take destiny 2
outside of gaming probably not a book
but what like
would you like a netflix series would
you like a one-off like anime movie
would you like lives
like what would you like to just see
them do with the stories that are out
there
destiny could easily be it's got a lot
of great sci-fi components it could
easily be
a as a series
a netflix series without doubt um
i'd prefer that over
i feel like if it did something like
anime or something they could easily
i don't know like retcon stuff i don't
know i feel like it wouldn't be taken as
seriously
as if they did like a live action party
that's true um but the thing is
it would also have the potential to be
like super big great i feel
because it's just like you know you got
like it's so sci-fi you've got like hive
and cabal
and and like just non-human characters
like is it
would it be a be great animation and
then that would upset me
so it'd be like i would have to be that
star wars level do you know
of alien creatures that just looked
freaking cool and i think that's pretty
tough man
yeah yeah especially with the budget
yeah
they're not a disney's level of uh
playing quite yet i'm sure so i was just
curious if you had a preference to
see something like on your uh tv screen
at home
yeah yeah um i guess a lot of questions
for you this is um
probably one of my final ones there's
been a lot of speculation about
what's going on with the morosov and
mars you know the whole thing with her
so like
you know what what do you think possibly
could be going on and then there's also
rumors i don't know if my boy screamer
is here
he's like she's that's have a thumb like
i've seen that going around
like there's a lot of marisol uh
theories so just what do you feel and
you're just
guessing you know what do you feel
what's going on i mean
what it's meant to be is i guess that uh
heiress mourners working with marisol to
take out sabbath is my general
impression okay that she'll probably
making a reappearance with the witch
queen
okay and we'll find out what she's been
doing um
they uh they released a dark future law
book uh
which revealed you know eris mourne was
the real witch queen
uh and betrayed everyone um
i think that's a massive red herring
it's a bit of a
bit of fun of you know destiny put
every fan theory into that book that
they could possibly squeeze in
including eris morgan being evil so i
feel like it was a
bit of a fun book rather than something
we take super seriously um
so i don't think aerosmall is going to
betray so i think it's going down that
path of
that's what that's what she's been
working out is is how to take out
sabathune and focusing on that threat
and uh
likelihood working with mara self and
that's probably all i've got
okay and and last question in reference
to it um
the connection with her and obviously
now
crow which is now you know a former
brother now
a guardian you know yeah the uldrin
so like um do you think they tie
the knot with those two characters as
far as uh
you know seamlessly just from a cohesion
standpoint bringing that full circle
oh they've got so much uh narrative
energy
uh with the crow they can do anything
and i think
they've done a really good job with crow
going from
probably one of the most hated
characters to one of the characters we
have the most empathy for
that's out of my moments for them that
i've got i've got when you asked me what
uh
that was his character his character
development continued that was yeah
yeah i think i actually really nailed
that i think that was a hard sell
um and the fact they could flip an
entire community to
being on crow's side with a couple of
pieces of dialogue from spider and a
couple of story points i think is
pretty special and uh they obviously
have a huge amount of
plot line a huge amount of string and
rope to play with with bringing back
marisol because she's she's a bit mean
yeah she didn't mean she's been mean to
her brother at the very least
uh and never really cared about it so
there's heaps of
family stuff that can um you know uh
tension between marisol and aldrin and
his character so i hope that
they do do something there i don't know
what it would be but so the theme of
today
is destiny is a story of
family problems you've got five family
brothers and sisters
mother daughter in cabal brother sister
going on here
those are the big ones i can pick up
real off the balance off my head so
yeah families are going to mess you up
they there's always going to be family
drama
yeah but on that note i know we got kind
of hitting our time window here so we
want to let you go
um if there's anything you've got coming
up for
your world as you said videos you want
to work on stuff they can look forward
to
just where they can find you the floor
is yours to let anybody who listens and
finds this one
um it's all yours right um
so i'll be working on because i know i
don't think all the last
man the what's the dead man's tale is
all out yet the book
so i'm saving the full summary for a
little bit longer
so next week i think i'll release that
today i'm going to work on
just a short video about callus in case
people haven't jumped into that book so
far just what what's going on with the
the real callus and uh maybe a
discussion about whether he's
dead or not um a couple hints
in the in that exotic mission um
which you probably already know it's
just the first couple entries but people
haven't read it i think will find it
interesting
and then i'll be streaming live on
twitch
every day except today is is
typically my day off um i appreciate you
when this podcast started
pretty pretty similar time like i used
to wrap up around now as well so
minus three hours from now is usually
when i when i head live every day
and that's that's it that's it i think
uh i'll see what other games come up too
so i'm always looking for new games to
play and and see what we can add to the
channel
bad enough brother man thank you again
for taking the time
huge fan of you man huge fan of you i
love what you do in the community love
how you deliver your content and i like
you actually expanding with the
diversity of your content it's been
really really cool i know we didn't get
a touch uh on low ufc i had to
throw it at the end but i when the world
was normal i had the pleasure
of having a drink with this man and
shout out to rick cackas and man at arms
and
we watched uh ben askren lose
consciousness in about two five seconds
that was a moment i will never forget
you threw up your drink i'd really like
oh my god
it was a classic moment at gcx you know
and i do
miss you know once the world gets back
to normal being able to hang out with uh
members of the destiny community you
were awesome you
showed a lot of love so much respect to
you in that and um
yeah man always a pleasure man always a
pleasure thank you thank you for having
me
appreciate your show for sure
uh yeah for you sir anything
to wrap your pc i'm sorry i didn't talk
about myself
yeah i mean that was like we're just
celebrating the island here so
yeah but first of all i want to shout
out the community obviously
you know this has been an extremely
brutal week for me and personally you
know and um
with real life physically coming off the
surgery and then uh too
close to dear friends passing away and
it was a lot of love
i thank y'all guys that sent me messages
and checked on me and see how i was
doing
it was it was rough you know i mean but
uh we getting through and uh
tomorrow uh as dizzy would like me to
continue iop and the tradition so we
will do that
and we will have jason ronald from xbox
the director the creator of the series x
and series s
he has agreed to still come on and um
it's gonna be fun we're gonna we're
gonna definitely have some
fun and again shout out to everybody who
uh came or at least uh stopped by for
the uh live stream we celebrated
dizzy's life and uh also uh give a shout
out to nintendo guru who uh
passed away as well so salute to
everybody community again
i felt the love the family also
expressed their uh thanks as well so uh
salute to you guys but that's what i got
going and i'm good to shout out to evan
i see you moving and shaking me at um
what'd you call it out there uh fire
team chat you were immortalized very
proud
very proud i saw your face up there with
you and paul tassie and uh keeping
things going and holding down the fort
while i've been kind of going through my
thing so salute to you and also for you
for checking on me
and see how i'm doing and stuff like
that wouldn't wouldn't have it any other
way and i'm just sorry everything had to
go through recently
so no yeah if you guys haven't checked
that out on ilp it was the celebration
of dizzy just
i didn't catch all but what i did
there's a lot of love
in in that stream so definitely go check
it out
for me uh you guys know still covering
destiny still covering outriders getting
ready for those going on
um but this month is gonna be i mean i
can't i can only play the demos so much
but they keep tweaking things i say that
i've already got too many hours so i'll
still keep touching on it just to stay
fresh and see if there's anything else
but
there's a lot of depth of that game so
i'm looking forward to pretty solid
month of that in april
other than that for now just kind of
seeing what keeps going on the destiny
train and then probably popping into
probably some random games i'm almost
done with immortals phoenix rising about
to finish that one
that's been a fun goofy game like if you
haven't played assassin's creed in a
while and you're not burnt out on open
worlds
immortals phoenix rising has like kind
of cheeky dry humor
dealing with greek gods and the combats
just kind of like fun and light-hearted
don't take it
seriously it's a good one um but that's
all i got i'm yvontas you guys can find
me everywhere
ilp you know iron lords podcast and of
course our awesome guest
sir milan games thank you very much it
was our pleasure having you
the uh the pinnacle of the laura
community here
we thank you for for joining us on this
one uh but for everybody in this episode
we are gonna go raid gamma trap
very fittingly he's swimming right now
so gonna send the raid over there so you
guys love the game
but for today march 6 episode number 139
thank you sir it has been
the last word